[Music]
have you given any thought
to where this ends
the table will never stop
you know this
no one
not even you
can kill everyone
you ready john
[Music]
wait up wait up what do you do with all
this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan's
died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero
do you have a therapist kid
good
i pick up garbage for a living about the
same thing meredith cleaned up the
streets
you mind your business on my mind i
don't believe you
are you okay
i'm cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop caring
and i stopped caring a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
[Music]
hey old man
try this
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and he's so
manly and batman so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
now
[Music]
listen to me billy the fate of the world
depends on it
[Music]
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
[Music]
will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
right now
i just threw a truck at a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
[Music]
no woman no crying
good friends we have and good friends
we've lost
along the way
in this great future
you can't forget your past
society
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
i am is
of the most powerful nation in the world
and my entire family
is gone
have i not given everything
and when i wake up
[Music]
my name's pill
the scratcher
we're orphans we live on the street and
the nobles sure are gonna take care of
us there you are cockroach
i got you
uh eleanor hello oh roland you're going
to be king prince roland i've ruled over
this kingdom since your father died and
i've done very well and you think that
because it's your birthday i'll just
hand you the throne never
i'm willing to help you out but in
exchange
i want the treasure your father left
it's up to you oh get away you beastly
thing
so thought about my proposition you know
the crowd is ready i am a princess now
we have to make you human again we'll go
see that sorceress in the cursed forest
she'll help you princess could you maybe
hire us huh you can come with me and my
weapon will protect you princess
let's do this
this is a rotten plan
i'm powerful and i intend to stay that
way
your highness princess we must act fast
for the prince will stay like this
forever
to prepare the antidote i'll need the
down from my unicorn
oh cockrell i dropped my poo i think i
did too get out i'm ready
[Music]
please lord
make me the biggest star the world has
ever known
so that i'll make it far far away from
this place
you know caring for your family during
these times is admirable
but you only get one take at this life
if only they would just die
pardon
nothing
[Applause]
i want to be special dancing up on the
screen like the pretty girls in the
pictures
i will not let you leave this farm again
i'm worried there may be something real
wrong with me
rumor has it they only take one gal per
town
we're looking for someone with x factor
it has to be me
how about a film nobody else has seen
it's illegal
will be eventually
i know what i've done
bad things
terrible awful murderous things
i want to be loved from as many people
as possible
but truth is i'm not really a good
person
here's the thing we're a team of thieves
and when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
revenge
truth be told
we help the wrong person steal the wrong
thing we didn't mean to unleash the
greatest evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it
so how do we pull that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need food give us a fighting
chance we're gonna need strength you got
this right i know you don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's an owl there
[Music]
be warned
there is evil here
i'm glad he's on our side
one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this i'm
a planner i make plans you've already
made plans so if the existing plan fails
i make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
my powers
are not a gift
but a curse
is born out of rage
[Music]
black adam
you believe you are not worthy
but you have two paths
you can be the destroyer of this world
or you can be a savior
the world needed a hero
[Applause]
instead it got me
[Music]
i thought i had something
that thing is stalking us
[Music]
we head for that island it'll come for
us again
it's not gonna stop
i got a letter today from auntie lizzie
she said bo's been working the fields
i can't imagine oh he just doesn't
understand how different things are in
mississippi are you listening yes
be small down there like this
[Music]
never thought anything would happen to
him
[Music]
meet the mummy
[Music]
he just wanted to go on vacation and
have fun with his cousins
but if my son could just
get his feet back onto the chicago soil
he'd be one happy kid
i don't know why i said that
[Music]
i wanna talk to you about that boy
they've gone for you
[Music]
it's hard to describe what a mother
knows
the first thing i noticed when i became
a mother was that my hands were busy
all the time
my hand knew him with my eyes closed
just like i know his laughter in a
crowded room
it's the same thing
when you know all of someone
this was my boy
emmett till
the body of emmett lewis hill has been
found dead
can i at least just fix them up a bit no
they have to see it for themselves
you tell me maybe i was risking your
life gonna help them
those pictures of your son
change people's lives
i
[Music]
the lynching of my son has shown me that
what happens to any of us anywhere in
the world
had better be the business of us all
[Music]
do
[Music]
the global pandemic has had an enormous
impact on our world our culture and our
very belief systems
[Music]
but there are other kinds of plagues
that visit us
and whom the gods would destroy
they first make mad with power
the mills of god grinds slowly
and exceedingly small
the bee
fertilizes the flower at roms
true power
requires camouflage
and if you want to don this mask dance
this mask you must sublimate yourself
and your identity
you must in fact stand in front of the
public and god
and obliterate yourself
[Music]
hey
at 907 this morning we experienced a
partial shutdown
so it's a cyber attack
i think i might have found something one
of our work experience students found it
do we know who's responsible russia most
likely fsb i'd like to know what we can
do to retaliate if we attack them again
it's just an ever escalating spiral
surely it has to stop this country has
faced an attack amounting to an act of
war it is our duty to respond
i have decided to declare a state of
emergency
lies like fire where's putin going with
this he wants to overturn the world
order
did we organize that counter
demonstration we organized both of them
[Applause]
what if the other side has already
predicted every step you'll take they
hit us again we have the stakes another
notch and before you know we're into a
cycle of escalation and a catastrophic
loss of life
there's been a massive leak of data from
gchq
this is far worse than anything by
snowden
the truth is they've been one step ahead
of us anticipated how we react to every
stage
shut it down
[Music]
come on let's go
[Music]
come and get me [ __ ]
go
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm so sorry i forgot to tell you but
you're not feeling very well and the
only way to cure it is if we stay home
all day and i tend to you and kiss you
and cook
bye security level yellow or residents
safe and accounted for
victory is safe and secure
here you can live the life you deserve
we can all live
frank has built something truly special
what he's created out here it's it's a
different way
a better way
victory has things money can't buy
i lived next door you wouldn't believe
the things i've heard jack and alice
only have time for each other
what is the
enemy of progress chaos yes
nasty word
[Music]
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
where it's safe
i was here when you got here
yeah you sleep in the bedroom
that's good just breathe
most of my patients have had nightmares
i have some pills i can prescribe for
that
violet where did you meet phil we met on
a train to boston he dropped her ticket
and he bent down picked it up gave it to
you right
[Music]
thank you for your loyalty
not everyone gets this opportunity
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
we're lying about everything
keep calm and carry on
it's all about control
i know exactly who you are
[Music]
i've been waiting for someone like you
someone
to challenge
me like a good girl
danny yeah had a chance to read that
article you sent me what do you think
you don't feel like it comes off a
little tone deaf
offensive even i don't feel like you
take me seriously as a writer that's
because you're not a writer
you're a photo editor
have you ever wanted to be noticed so
badly hi mom you want to hang out
tonight
[Music]
you didn't even care what it was for all
in oh [ __ ] what up honey danny from work
danny yo
i love your videos man
thanks b
so what are you i'm a writer
i'm looking to develop my work by
traveling
going to paris for it
[ __ ]
hey get picked i'm gonna get lots of
pics yeah i'll throw them all up on the
ground right
[ __ ]
emma i got invited to a writer's retreat
in paris
yes really
starting my morning right now where's my
baguette
[Music]
we have some breaking news at this hour
a string of terrorist attacks struck
paris this morning
leaving dozens dead and many more
injured
[ __ ]
like 26.77 now
danny
she's okay
we are here with the girl of the moment
you've been blowing up our insta feet
speaking of bombings
really glad you're not good me too
isn't she so strong
[Applause]
oh my god you're the girl from the paris
attack
let's not forget the signature red beret
hi i'm danny rowan welcome to group
we're all survivors here do you want to
share
you're not okay that's okay
the internet likes to turn victims into
villains
oh no it doesn't seem to be happening to
me
you should be prepared if it does
we need to talk
be careful what you [ __ ] wish for
so what are we supposed to feel bad for
you
hey lizzy with my nine o'clock
sorry about the game but we're going to
have fun tonight
let me guess another it conference i'm
going to be back in a couple days toms
hey mom dad has a work emergency so can
you come pick me up i love it when you
call me mom let's throw a rager
what's happening
please don't
[Music]
this is so tight
it's some kind of superhero lair your
dad's a superhero
what no my dad can't handle hot wings
step step step into the spotlight check
this out
i have a crazy idea
step into the spotlight
please don't kill me
now that's fast
we got him
[Music]
whoever has this technology can do
anything
we gotta save my dad's tech before they
destroy the world
we got this
what are you gonna do tickle torture me
oh dude that was too long
that was way too long
whoa whoa don't you i'm the i.t guy i
was alerted to a security breach
why couldn't you tell me about your
secret identity how am i supposed to say
oh by the way some alien power source
chose me to be the guardian of the
planet
it makes you sound crazy right yes
playtime's over kids
prepare for war
[Music]
things are warm
yeah so hot you got the winter suit
[Music]
bella so good to see you i'm sorry it's
under such terrible circumstances yeah
it's fine when your father passed he
left you something
very funny is that a jerk
no congratulations you have a boat right
i have a part
cheers cheers i know a place we can go
hey no one's supposed to be out here get
your hands up
[Music]
wake up the parts moving
four mechanical locks
if we get through all those we throw the
biometric lock we gotta get off this one
i don't know how many guys
where's your chest somewhere in the
middle of the ocean
push the red button
[Music]
[Music]
he stole my part
i am live outside the tamluwan cave
complex in the northern thai province of
chiang rai
we've been following the story of the
wild wars football team 12 boys and
their coach trapped in a cave system in
thailand
they went up this road and into this
cave
and that's the last time they were seen
whether they're still alive is really
anyone's guess
the authorities have three options on
the table number one drill holes into
the mountain create an alternative
passage how much is underwater the study
passage is approximately one kilometer
long so the last option is to do it the
hard way
these are the best cave divers in the
world there's no one else like that
you've got these guys over here
you need to let them do their job
how many of you 13.
each of the lead divers will take one
boy each and lead them from chamber nine
to chamber three and what are the odds i
can see 60 70 success rate
sir we may lose three or four
that weather changes you may lose hope
in getting even one of them out alive
did you hear about the soccer team stuck
in a cave in thailand no
they all
i'm died we're all good with that
sedation business we have no choice it's
like this well there's no dying
not all these boys might make it home
it's a story of heroism and sacrifice
that has captivated the whole world
i've had a lot of time to think and i
made the decision i'm not gonna go back
to school after winter break what
ain't got no hope
obviously you need to hear this you're
already at a professional level of
drawing for what you want to do
everything in your portfolio needs to be
very clearly coming from who you are
all my heroes didn't go to college do
you know what you get with the ged you
know what kind of job you would get what
gas station i'd love to work in a gas
station
you know i'm looking at a place in
trenton later whoa
trenton
um where would i be staying stephen's
room
hi there
hey
uh robert meet our friend wallace so it
says here you worked for a company
called image years like image comics
i wasn't an artist
nobody get all excited
what would it take for a drawing lesson
honestly you consider yourself a
cartoonist right i pay you how much
[Music]
this is really crazy for me i've just
never met a professional cartoonist
before that's a big deal
i know you need to be harder on yourself
miles if you want to get someplace you
gotta you gotta be harder on yourself
ring a bell
well you're working for cheryl right
yeah sometimes
[Music]
you think she's good looking um i'm just
gonna be a minute
okay you are truly
delicious
who's that that's my friend wallace i
forgot to tell you i invited him damn it
look i don't know you or what you're
capable of what's going on in there
robert open the door he's a horrible man
what happens if you come out ruin which
is what's gonna happen
[Music]
it's meant to be fun that's why they
call them with funnies they don't call
them the funniest for no reason
just space up to the fact that you
failed yeah but he failed with soul
okay
are you there david
you're aware of a deeper existence
maybe a temporary reassurance that
indeed there is no beginning no end
and you find yourself struggling to
comprehend a deep mystery
[Music]
ever since i was 16 i was determined to
have the greatest adventure that only
one person could ever have
[Music]
i'm an alligator
[Music]
silly
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
oh yeah
[Applause]
what's your fantasy
zoe
you want
retribution
against
him
his friends
everyone he loves
set me free
[Music]
and we'll play a new game
a game of chaos
strife
[Music]
and pain
hey
allison
she's alive she's back
[Music]
you